despite dozens of companies looking for  workers unemployment rates are actually  on the rise in  several counties across the state here  in clark county unemployment stands at 9  percent  that is a large improvement from this  time last year but dieter is working  hard to get people back to work in the  meantime there are still problems with  the department's website  some ui claimants are getting an error  message still when they're trying to  file  others are able to call in their claim  but not  able to provide proof that they're  looking for work now many are worried  they won't get paid this month  deter did not provide a timeline for  when this issue will be fixed but at  this point  they are urging you to call in your  claim